campus McDonald de MCGill.
- Une vieille grange en pierres,
qui n'a rien d'un musée, abrite
pourtant des pièces uniques
de l'aviation.
Comme cette réplique, grandeur
nature F F Fairchild FC-2
construit à Montréal par
la Canadian Vickers, à partir
de 1928.
ERIC CAMPBELL, bénévole,
Musée de l'aviation de Montréal
- C'est le premier avion
au Canada, avec une
cabine chauffée.
- Ou ce Curtiss-Reid, biplace,
fabriqué à Cartierville, aussi à
la fin des années 20.
- C'est très intéressant
le cockpit, il y a un "compa
dedans qui est d'origine,
qui vaut beaucoup d'argent
maintenant.
- Une dizaine de bénévoles,
la plupart des retraités
du milieu de l'aviation,
s'affairent à restaurer
de vieux avions.
Comme Johmamamamanton,
un ancien pilote d'Air Canada,
avec, a son actif, 22 000 heures
de vol.
JOHN DUCKMANTON,
pilorarararaité d'Air Canada
- Je suis un pilote retraité
d'Air Canada, je prends
ma retraite depuis 17 ans.
- Vous avez piloté quoi chez
Air Canada, quel avion?
- Le dc-9, le boeing 767,
l'airbus 310-20.
- Autre appareil unique:
un Blériota a a a volé
à Montréal en 1910.
- Le premier avion qui a volé
par dessus montréal pour
50 minutes.
- Des avions, mais aussi
d'anciens simulateurs de vol.
KEN FINCKEN, ingénieur retraité
de CAE de Montréal
- Ça, ça prend du temps.
Caiaiaiaiait en pièces toutes
détachées. C'est le fun, puis
comme c'est faite dans
les années 40, c'est très
intéressant.
- Un musée qui cherche un nouvel
emplacement et qui souhaite
devenir une référence pour
les passionnés de l'aviation.
- On cherche de l'argent pour
monter des fonds, pour
une expansion.
- Un petit musée consacré
à la conservation de l'histoire
aéronautique, avec une attention
particulière aux réalisations
québecoises. Tout ça, grace
à des bénévoles dévoués.
Ici, Jacques Bissonnet,
Radio-Canada,
Sainte-Anne-de-Bellevue.